right here
my
did you just
go forward
sure
it yes like uh
hello
what are you talking wait wait wait a
minute what are you talking about
got it guys
and i'm back at the white house
uh
yes
what like seven thirty
um
uh
oh my god
you know
ferris good afternoon to you while there
are a couple of republicans who do agree
with the minority leader chuck schumer
that this decision should be left
for the next president there are now 51
republicans who say
they are on board for a vote before the
election so now it comes down to a
matter of climate
can this all get done before november
the 3rd in an interview earlier today
president trump said
he is close in his own mind as to who
his nominee is going to be
and he believes there is time to get
that person through before november
so who are those top candidates well the
president yesterday met with one of them
amy coney barrett from the 7th circuit
court of appeals
she is taken by many people to be the
front runner she was a
a potential candidate last time around
when justice kennedy retired ultimately
that position was filled
by brett kavanaugh another leading
contender is said to be barbara lagoa
of the 11th circuit court of appeals she
lives in miami
she could potentially help the president
some of her supporters are saying
with hispanic voters but there is
concern because she's only been on the
federal bench
for a year she was with the florida
supreme court before that that her
federal record is a little bit too
thin for a supreme court nominee the
president has now also brought up
the name of joe larson from the sixth
third quarter fields
a couple of times though i am told that
joe larson is probably a little further
down on the list
maybe number three or number four so now
you've got your list of amy coney
barrett
and then maybe joan larson and allison
rushing still
in there uh in contention as well though
some people think it's too early for her
but she has
a lot of support harris among
evangelicals
who i'm told they've been burning up the
phone lines here at the white house
singing for praises
in terms of the announcement on saturday
the president has got a pre-planned
rally in the evening
in pennsylvania on saturday so it's
likely that the announcement will
probably be
sometime late in the afternoon the
president will introduce the nation to
his nominee and then he'll go off to
pennsylvania
to bang the drum for why that person
should be confirmed before november
all right you want me at the end too
right
okay
okay
heading into the fallout
just here
i'll take these things off
i mean i've been working um
sticking it on
yes
um
you
two minute warning
much
hello everyone nancy pelosi
chuck schumer and alexandria
ocasio-cortez have officially shown
their blatant disregard for the united
states constitution
apparently it is now a high crime and
misdemeanor
worthy of impeachment for a lawfully
elected
president of the united states to
exercise his constitutional duty
article 2 section 2 of the constitution
of the constitution clearly states
that the president quote shall nominate
end quote justices of the supreme court
when a vacancy
occurs no matter the time no matter the
politics of the day
the president is the president there's
nothing in the constitution
that says the president stopped seeing
the president
in an election year the president has
already appointed two
strong conservative justices to the
supreme court
justices who will interpret the
constitution as written
now he will nominate a third as senator
ted cruz reminds us
we're one vote away from seeing our
religious liberty
votes stripped away from our free speech
stripped away
from our second amendment being stripped
away just one vote
contrast the president's solemn
constitutional duty
with democrats search and destroy
politics
nancy pelosi has vowed to attack the
president with quote
arrows speaker pelosi will not rule out
impeaching this president for doing his
job
for fulfilled for fulfilling his
constitutional obligation
aoc said that impeachment is an option
quote on the table
while chuck schumer stood by nodding
approvingly
the plan of house democrats is so
rapidly radical
that even democrat senator tim kaine has
rebuked the idea
calling the idea of using impeachment to
delay a supreme court
vote quote foolish some democrats
already have a back-up plan if they
don't get their way on this nomination
congressman joe kennedy said if he holds
a vote in 2020 we pack the court in
2021.
it's that simple senator ed markey went
further
no supreme court vacancies filled in an
election year he said
if he violates it when democrats control
the senate in the next congress we must
abolish the filibuster
and expand the supreme court senator
the president is elected to a four year
term
you cannot unilaterally reduce it to
three years the president
is the president democrats cannot win
their argument on the merits
they cannot win on precedent so they
must search
and destroy don lemon said the quiet the
quiet part out loud last night he said
this
we're going to have to blow up the
entire system
if the president does his job as
outlined
in the constitution that's the
difference between republicans and
democrats
we fight to protect the system we fight
to protect the constitution
when democrats say outright we are going
to blow up the entire system because we
do not get our way
this president will proceed undaunted by
democrat threats
president trump will fulfill his duty
president trump
will appoint the next supreme court
justice president trump will protect
religious liberty
president trump will protect our freedom
of speech
president trump will protect our second
amendment
under this president our rights will be
upheld our constitution safeguarded
and this president will fill that seat
and with that i'll take questions
jim uh kelly as you know uh the country
has hit 200 000
deaths from the coronavirus what do you
say to americans who are
outraged over this and blame this
administration
for so many lives lost in this country
well as you've heard
several doctors in the task force task
force note from this podium uh we were
looking at the prospect of
two million people potentially perishing
from the coronavirus in this country uh
we agree when
even one life is lost but the fact that
we have no
the fact that that we have come nowhere
near that number as a testament to this
president president taking immediate
action
uh to shutting down travel from china uh
when the other party democrats were
saying that was xenophobic
uh for shutting down travel for europe
for developing uh landmark therapeutics
that are working like remdesseviere
um and when you look at the fact that
excess mortality europe has experienced
a 28
higher excess mortality rate than the
united states it's a testament to the
hard work done by the task force and
this president
last night the president said at one of
his rallies
about the virus i think he was talking
about younger americans he said it
affects virtually nobody
uh by the way over your schools
everybody open your schools
uh but he said to bob woodward it's not
just
old it's not just older people it's
young people too
at 200 000 deaths shouldn't the
president be telling people the truth
about this virus at his rallies the
president is telling people the truth
and you're right
jim that he was talking about it affects
virtually nobody
and that it doesn't affect young people
he's not telling the truth
jim but you're again taking the
president out of context i have his full
quote here
and you're right that he was referring
to young people he said this
i'm not taking it out of context if i
said he was talking about younger people
that i'm not taking out
you're you are taking it out of context
because you're making an assertion that
he's not giving critical information
when in fact he is
and i will underscore exactly what he
said and he said this
you know in some states thousands of
people
um and they've had nobody young below
the age of 18 like
nobody they have a strong immune system
that is factually true
you can go to the american academy of
pediatrics website uh the children's
hospital association and they list out
a number of states that have had zero
pediatric deaths
and they've spread it to older people
and i've known this since the very
beginning and for the president of the
united states of 200 000
deaths to go out to his rallies and say
something like
if it virtually affects nobody and that
in some states
it's not affecting young people that is
glossing over the fact
and really diminishing the fact that
young people can catch this virus and
spread it
over people younger people can also be
sickened and killed by this virus
do you have the quote there with you yes
it is exactly as i just read it to you
that in
several states uh they have had zero
pediatric deaths i've have the entire
list here arkansas delaware district of
columbia
iowa i uh hawaii idaho kansas and the
list goes on
and as you may not know jim uh this the
covid
has a 0.01 mortality rate uh before
people uh under the age of 18. so it
does it is not a disease that affects
young people in the same way as older
people which is the exact point the
president
was making last night yes uh one person
killed who does believe that the
president has the constitutional
authority to make a nomination for the
supreme court and that the senate has
the constitutional
obligation to provide advice and consent
is utah senator mitt romney
over the course of the last three and a
half years the president and romney have
often found themselves at odd
odds have said unkind if not intemper
things
about each other how is the president
feeling about mitt romney today
i haven't spoken to him about senator
romney but senator romney is recognizing
um what any of us who take a clear-eyed
look at pres
of at precedent recognize that the
president is on our side here
uh 29 times has there been an
appointment
during an election year 29 times
and when you break down those numbers 19
times when those nominations
were made the senate and the president
were of the same party
17 of those 19 times uh that nominee
went on to be confirmed
the 10 times when it was a difference in
party between republicans and democrats
in the senate and the presidency
only two went on to be confirmed so
precedent is on our side
but democrats are trying to have it both
ways here and i would
cite dan mclaughlin a national review
who said this he's exactly right
choosing not to fill a vacancy
would be a historically unprecedented
act of unilateral
disarmament so let me just follow up on
that so timing now is the next issue the
president will have
37 or 38 days from the time he makes the
announcement
to the last time that he could ever vote
before the election
past years john paul stevens was
nominated and confirmed in 19 days
chief justice john roberts 24. uh
justice
sandra day o'connor in 33 times were
different back then
than they are now can you do it in 37
days we certainly believe we can
um you've heard very optimistic words
from senator graham
how will you do it well we will go about
this um the way we always have by
putting forward a constitution abiding
textualist originalist that
we believe the american people will
appreciate and we believe we'll
get through the approval process the
nomination confirmation
process i should say quite quickly yes
kevin two
questions um on the two hundred thousand
deaths
will the will the president recognize
that publicly
today um at his speech or on twitter
is this something that he
would like to express
remorse over or simply to people who
have lost the president throughout this
pandemic has done
just that um he has said before that it
keeps him up at night thinking of
incredibly seriously um and what he's
done is he's worked harder um each and
every day
he works hard puts his head down and i
think that's very evident in the
administration's historic response the
largest
mobilization of the private sector since
world war ii
the fact that we got working
therapeutics delivered to the american
people the fact that vaccine
frankly this will be the fastest pace
for a vaccine for a novel pathogen in
history
as we seek to reach that goal by the end
of the year that's what the president
does he takes this seriously
i'm in the fact that you've seen the
fatality rate that has fallen 85
since april and the fact that only 1.5
percent of emergency room visits
are now people sick with covet is a real
testament to the hard work done by the
task force and president trump
could you speak a bit about why the
president
prefers to have the confirmation
vote before the election how does he
think this is going to help
cory gardner and joni erst and
republicans keep the majority in the
senate
well the president would like to see a
confirmation process that is fair
i think one of the low points for this
process
whereas the kavanaugh hearings and what
democrats did there making
baseless allegations against justice
kavanaugh someone respected
um prior to president trump appointing
him by everyone and democrats really
dragged his name through the mud what
happened there was a travesty
i mean the president wants to see a fair
confirmation process and he wants to see
one
uh that does not look um like what what
happened to kavanaugh that was a real
low point for democrats
democratic stumbles uh into kavanaugh
uh confirmation process will help
republicans
he thinks look democrats really showed
um
them themselves at the lowest point on
that confirmation process
i think the american people saw
democrats for the partisan games that
they play and i think the american
people are looking now and seeing
nancy pelosi and chuck schumer talking
about impeachment for executing
your power in article two section two
it's really um inane and outlandish the
things they're suggesting and once again
they seem to be
doubling down on their kavanaugh
approach didn't work out too well with
justice kavanaugh
won't work out too well this time in an
election year yes
one on the court first on covet if i can
the president recently gave himself an a
plus for his handling of covid but a d
for his
pr what would good pr look like when 200
000 americans are dead um what the
president
was saying is that he wants to make sure
that we get good information to the
american people and that's something
that i think we've
done um and this president he's provided
information at times that was not true
he said he was downplaying it so
purposefully he was providing
information at times that was not fully
that's absolutely inaccurate um the
president never downplayed critical
health information uh the president
never downplayed our covid
response uh and you can just see that by
the historic effort that we've put
forward and i would also point you to dr
fauci uh who said i don't recall
anything different in our discussions
with the president
uh that he said things quite similarly
in public and
he was asked directly by none other than
john roberts did you ever get the sense
that he was or wasn't playing this down
no no i didn't and that's an assertion
echoed by the vice president our
response
uh when you look that 100 million tests
that we've exceeded the vaccine on
record pace
the therapeutics the fact that we've
brought fatality down by 85
this was a novel pathogen that came in
for which there were no tests and there
were no identified therapeutics
but they were identified very quickly
and also with regard to the vaccine when
you look at the notion that we are
manufacturing this at commercial levels
uh which i was told by uh by dr salawi
that that normally takes years to do
um and we're already producing um the
goal is 100 million doses by the end of
the year that's a testament to this
president and his response
none of these vaccines are effective
what is plan b for the white house
well if you're asking a hypothetical we
have six vaccines
we have six american vaccines that we've
identified um
three of them in phase three clinical
trial there's also um
one there's well we're getting there and
by the end of the year is the goal and
when you say what we do if they're not
approved we all hope for good news but
what if they're not approved
with the white house we have we have six
candidates we are a strong belief uh
that we will identify one hopefully more
than one working
vaccine uh by the end of the year
producing them in advance we already
have a distribution plan and when you
compare this i think context matters
ebola taking 14 months
to get to phase three clinical trial we
already have two candidates in phase
three clinical trial ebola took
three years to get to completion uh we
will have done this in under a year the
fastest rate for a novel pathogen in
history
justin the president did retweet today a
segment from rush limbaugh where
limbaugh suggested
it would be great if republicans skipped
committee hearings
on this pick altogether does the
president want republicans
to skip committee hearings they're a
co-equal branch of government why is he
directing them to do anything the
president is a fan of rush limbaugh
appreciates his commentary and
therefore retweeted it but we're working
with the senate right now on
that confirmation process and senator
graham has said it looks like it will be
on a three-day timeline
justin he wants the committee to go
forward justin
um one on the scottish and then one on
the stimulus um
can you confirm that the president's
planning to meet with judge lagoa
and florida well he's down there this
week
and he said yesterday that he had spoken
to some candidates beforehand
i know that uh judge barrett was in here
yesterday but i was wondering if he
could talk about any of the others that
he may have already had contact with
yeah i won't get into his private
meetings you will find out which
constitution abiding textualists and
originalists he
uh is appointing on saturday and then on
the stimulus it's been kind of a rocky
couple days on wall street i think
there's concern that the supreme court
fight
may sort of kill the the last gasps of
getting a stimulus
bill done before the election so the
white house agreed that that's probably
not going to happen until
after the election if at all or if you
are still hopeful
you know the president said when the
time is right uh he'd be willing to
reach out to speaker pelosi
it seems like we're getting down into
the last legislative days before the
election
is the time now right yeah we've um
wanted to see a
phase four uh relief bill gets the
american people it's why the chief of
staff and secretary mnuchin
have been in negotiations unfortunately
though they've been in negotiations with
a
fundamentally unserious partisan name
speaker pelosi
who when we would exceed what she asked
for with school funding let's say
she then would reject the money that was
in excess of what she had previously
asked for
um democrats i think showed what they
were about when they filibustered a bill
that would have provided 300
a week to the american people through
december 27th they filibustered that i
believe
last week so at this point um the onus
is really on speaker pelosi
um we encourage her to send one-off
bills perhaps
airline funding or other elements that
we could work through the process to get
to the american people it's always been
this president's priority
to do that so you don't see a kind of
big stimulus bill but you might see
one-off bills before elections yeah the
onus is on nancy pelosi you know we've
come up in our number
um to 1.5 trillion so it's possible
should she
become serious in these negotiations but
at this point if she doesn't want to
deliver relief to the american people to
that degree then she can win off some
bills
that we would look at and be happy to
move forward with because the priority
has always been getting money to
the american people which is why the
president has had those eos on evictions
and unemployment insurance
and student loans and evictions yes
the first presidential debates a week
from today how do you expect the supreme
court issue to impact that debate yeah
so
um you know a lot of that is for the
campaign with regards uh to the debate
so i'd have to refer you there
um but i think the american people are
going to get a very clear-eyed look
as they have with the previous two
nominees we've made of what this
president
stands for that he wants a judge who
will protect our fundamental rights our
essential liberties who looks at the
constitution
as written i'm not trying to fancifully
interpret that document
who looks at the plain meaning of
statutes and
implements that and rules in a way that
a true textualist would
this is the president who will protect
the second amendment who will protect
the first amendment and these
fundamental rights are at stake
should a another should another party
have their way
with the judiciary but this president
some will continue to appoint justices
in the mold
of gorsuch and of justice kavanaugh
separately
the democrats are threatening to add
justices
to the supreme court as you mentioned
does that concern you at all as you go
about this process
yeah that's uh it's unfortunately
a another example of trying to blow up
the system if you don't get your way
democrats will blow up the system they
will change the system they will trample
on the constitution
and you know i would point them to the
words of justice ginsburg who called
court packing a bad idea
she called it partisan she said nine
seems to be a good number i think
packing the court was a bad idea when
president franklin delano roosevelt
tried it and i'm not in favor
of all of that yes anita um
i had a question on the virus but i
wanted to follow up on justin
he um asked about the speaker has the
president called the speaker
about the recovery bill and why not if
he wants to get this done
is he calling other lawmakers as well
i'm not
aware of any conversation that they've
had uh there have been communications
through the chief of staff
through the secretary of treasury but
until um speaker pelosi becomes serious
in her negotiating instead of
uh she's engaging in political drama
we're really at a stalemate so it's
really the ball is in her court to
become serious in these negotiations the
president called
than mark meadows correct they've
they've been negotiating and uh when we
believe this
the speaker's in a serious spot we can
move forward with other conversations
but at this point
um when you ask for a certain amount of
school funding we exceed that and then
you reject the excess for
school funding and it just really shows
where her mindset's at my question on
the virus was
that some polls are showing that a
majority of americans don't trust what
the president is saying
on the virus vaccine and i wondered
you keep you all keep talking about the
vaccine possibly coming out
how are you going to get people to
believe that the vaccine is safe and
that people should go
get it when it does come out what do you
what is the process going to be
looking like yeah so i think um first i
want to point
out that several of the doctors have
been on the record
and have said that this vaccine is going
through the same rigorous
process it should um as dr hanna said
i've repeatedly said that all fda
decisions have been and will continue to
be based
solely on good science and data as dr
fauci said
certainly there are no corners being cut
here uh
and several others like secretary azar
have been on the record on this so
um the members of the task force have
all said this is going through the
rigorous fda process
and it will be a good safe and effective
vaccine yes
question on the vaccine how soon would
the president feel comfortable taking a
vaccine himself
and would he support a non-american
vaccine perhaps even
from china or russia so um first i would
say
this that the president has been on the
record saying i'm happy to be
the first person to take the vaccine or
the last person whatever is best for the
american people
um he believes it will be a safe and
effective vaccine and one he would
certainly
be open to taking um and he said this um
i'm going to really say something that
is not like me i don't care i just want
to get a vaccine that
works i really don't care if it's
another country i'll take my hat off to
them but
currently i think the other vaccine and
phase 3 clinical trial
um is the one in oxford yes
just to clarify on the mitt romney
development
with senator romney's announcement does
the president
think he actually has a bulletproof
group of republicans who will vote no
matter what even before the nominee is
named
or does he fear some defections after
that nominee is named
and the confirmation hearings begin no
he thinks um
his nominee is going to be someone with
a stellar track record
um someone who as i've mentioned several
of the qualities will be a textualist
who will be an originalist and someone
who we believe republicans will
will really rally around um and senator
graham said that he believes that he'll
have the votes and
you know leave it to the senators at
this point but
this will be a nominee that will really
i think unify republicans
does he think he has 51. he was i've
missed the first part about you
president has been a pretty good nose
counter
does he think he has 51. yeah i think at
this point he's just trying to select
the nominee i haven't spoken to him
about the vote count
um but we believe that republicans will
remain unified and we believe that this
nominee
will get across the finish line yes the
president is giving a health care speech
on thursday is this finally going to be
his long-awaited
comprehensive healthcare policy because
there are a doubt that such a thing
actually
exists no it certainly does exist uh the
president
um in the next week or so will be laying
out his vision for healthcare some of
that has already
uh been put out there like telemedicine
um
and lowering the cost of drugs but the
president
and protecting pre-existing conditions
but the president will be laying out
some additional
health care steps in the coming i would
say two weeks
yamiche hi thanks so much bailey um
i have two questions the first is the
president has said roe v
raid would be overturned if he got a
chance to change the balance on the
court he said in 2016
quote if we put another two or perhaps
three justices on
that will happen is that the ultimate
goal here to overturn
roe v raid the president and the
administration would not ask
a judge to prejudge a case
and i would point you to um the rules
set by
none other than senator joe biden um at
the confirmation hearing of ruth bader
ginsburg
when he instructed no questions on how
ginsberg will decide any specific
case that would come before her i mean
as justice ginberg
ginsburg said in her uh confirmation no
hints no forecasts no previews
um and cannon five of the model code of
judicial conduct also
uh reflects that a judge should refrain
from giving um specific viewpoints on
cases
controversies or issues whether or not
the president's
quote in 2016 whether he still stands by
that that he would like to see it
overturned
the president's um philosophy as he's
moving forward with this nomination
process
is he's looking at a judge that has
certain qualities that is someone who
looks at the constitution and interprets
it as written
interprets the plain meaning of statutes
as written and then we'll be a
textualist and an originalist
second question about the virus um again
we've marked the fact that 200 000
americans have died from the coronavirus
could you again try to reconcile the
president telling
bob woodward that plenty of young people
quote his words plenty of young people
are affected by the coronavirus with him
saying last night in front of
a crowd that virtually nobody young
dies or anything it's affected by this
virus i'm wondering if you could just
reconcile those two
why did he tell bob woodward that plenty
of young people are impacted by this
virus but not say that
in front of a crowd well as you know
this was a novel pathogen we now know a
lot more
about covet today and the president
actually said that in a speech last
night right before on the comments he
made he said we now know a lot more
about the virus and we know that
elderly people particularly those with
comorbidities are
affected by it and we know that young
people are by and large
um and in some states um there's been no
young people
that have succumbed to this disease and
i've listed off a few of the states for
you
i mean we know that a very very um small
percentage of those under 18
um have actually perished parish because
of covid i mean it was a novel pathogen
now we know a lot more about it who it
affects who our most vulnerable are
which is why we've
surged testing to communities that are
vulnerable and we'll continue
to make sure that our elderly those
comorbidities are protected
yes i continue to try to like not have
panic
he told bob woodward that he wanted to
downplay it and play it down to not
cause panic he's you don't think he's
doing that still the president has never
downplayed critical health information
um dr fauci as i noted to you um said
point blank
no he uh he didn't and that's an
assertion of vice president
vice president pence who led the task
force uh made as well yes
thanks kaylee um the americans filed an
appeal to the supreme court
on apportionment um trying to make sure
that people in the country
illegally are not counted when
congressional seats are handed out
sorry a little muffled um texas is one
of the states that would
lose a seat uh if those people are not
counted
um the constitution says that the people
in a state
or the number that are used for
apportionment are those
are people in the country legally not
people and why does the president not
want texas to have
more seats rather than fewer in the us
house yeah i haven't done a particular
a deep dive into that legal case and i
can look into it and get back to you
yes so ask a separate question at the
top of this um you mentioned the
democrats have talked about impeachment
and you also said that the president
doesn't stop being president in the last
year
is there any not not that they're
actually going through the impeachment
at the moment but is there anything
to prevent an impeachment in the final
months of the presidency
um well first i mean to pursue
impeachment
based on someone executing their lawful
duty their constitutional duty is just
preposterous and
it told us a whole lot about what
democrats use impeachment for it shows
that
they've always viewed impeachment at
least in the nancy pelosi
era as a partisan tool to take down a
sitting president to
disempower the american people who voted
to empower president trump
they've used impeachment as a political
tool and that is
that will be the the history and the
record of nancy pelosi and now she's on
the record
saying that she would even use
impeachment uh to try to undo
the constitution particularly article
two section two uh that is shameful but
unsurprising from the speaker
yes in his u.n speech president trump
mentioned the reduction of carbon
emission in the u.s
of what sorry emission in the u.s
okay i can't really hear you carbon
emission okay
saying it was a good thing because it's
connected with the reduction of use of
coal
is it to say that decline of coal is a
good thing
um i would just note that on greenhouse
gas emissions uh
we have decreased them as the us has
become number one in the oil in the oil
and natural gas production but we've
simultaneously
uh reduced greenhouse emissions yes i
also wanted to follow up on the
uh speech the president prepared for the
un general assembly he hit china really
hard and
the chinese ambassador and introducing
president xi responded accusing the
president
of bullying protectionism and
unilateralism
wondering what the white house response
is to that and then
how concerned is this white house this
growing rift between the world's two
largest economies is going to
hurt the efforts to combat coronavirus
um let me just say nothing has
hurt the efforts to combat the
coronavirus more than
more than china concealing information
about kovid 19 from the very beginning
what china did was inexcusable in
partnership with the who
hid critical information about
transmission of kovid from us
about the severity of coven not just
from us but from the world
uh there's no bigger bully uh than than
china
when it comes to covid um and that's
pretty clear and just look at what
happened at the w.h.o
yeah just one quick follow-up with
regard to the
intelligence around the poisoning of the
russian opposition leader
the president said we'll talk about that
another time just trying to get a sense
of has the president reviewed the german
assessment
is he rejecting that assessment that he
was indeed
poisoned the no the united states um as
president of the g7 um and joined by our
g7
partners has condemned in the strongest
possible terms
the confirmed poisoning and germany
briefed the g7 on clinical and toxic
logical findings by medical experts in a
specialized germ
german armed forces laboratory
determined
that mr navalny was the victim of an
attack with a chemical nerve agent
um a substance developed by russia and
any use of chemical weapons anywhere
anytime by anyone
under any circumstance is unacceptable
let the u.s response be done
i again i've told you so far that the
united states um
has condemned it along with g7 and rest
assured
um there's been no one tougher on russia
than this country you've seen what we've
done with sanctions
and expelling diplomats among other
actions yes
chanel haley expanding on the last
couple of questions about the u.n speech
president does hit china pretty hard
specifically on china's slave labor
practices and ethnic cleansing
but then interestingly he dives into
their environmental record
china dumps millions and millions of
tons of plastic and trash into the
oceans
overfishes other countries waters
destroys vast swathes of coral reefs and
emits more toxic
mercury into the atmosphere than any
country anywhere in the world
how responsive have the united states
has allies been
to this message from the president and
on
confronting china on these fronts in
particular i would say
the world is unified um and condemning
some of the human rights
uh violations um by uh china
um and also i would know just on the
issue of co2 emissions
there's no bigger emitter than china
itself charlotte
thank you haley um a heritage foundation
report has discovered a financial link
between
an organization linked to black lives
matter and
a pro-chinese regime group is that
something that the white house
would investigate and is that something
you're concerned about
and so i haven't seen uh that particular
reporting
um but just on the note of some of the
violence that we've been seeing
i would just point out this new york
times article that came out
terence moses was watching protesters
against police brutality marched down
on his quiet residential street one
recent evening when some in the group
of a few hundred suddenly stopped and
started yelling
mr moses was initially not sure what the
protesters were upset about but as he
got closer
he saw it it was his neighbor who had an
american flag on display
it went from a peaceful march calling
out the names to all of a sudden bang
how dare you fly the american flag said
mr moses
who is black and runs a non-profit group
in the portland oregon area
they said take it down they wouldn't
leave they said they're going to come
back
and burn down the house mr moses and
others blocked the demonstrators and
told them to leave
uh mr moses said we don't go around
terrorizing folks to try and force them
to do something
they don't want to do uh who runs a
non-profit group that provide support
for local homelessness people
he said i'm a veteran i'm for these
liberties i'm going to shameful the
violence we've seen in our cities that
is now
us filling into suburbs across the
country um and good work and good
reporting
by the new york times on that now i'd
like to invite lieutenant general keith
kellogg to the podium
to discuss a disgruntled former detailee
general kellogg is a three-star general
a veteran of the vietnam war in
operation
desert storm general kellogg has been
supporting president trump from the
beginning
and has been by the president's side for
major foreign policy decisions uh
general kellogg please
thanks kaylee good afternoon i'm keith
kellogg
olivia troy worked for me i fired her
the reason i fired her was her
performances started to drop after six
months
working on the task force as a back
bencher
she was responsible for coordinating
meetings
bringing people together and when the
performance level dropped off i went to
the vice president united states
and recommended she leave i'm the one
that escorted her off the compound
what she has said i have never heard
that's never happened
and i've been through every single
meeting of the task force
been with the president and the vice
president
through every meeting what bothers me
about what olivia said
is by insinuation the disparagement
of the task force the vice president
and the president of the united states
when you look at what the task force
has done we are now facing the worst
pandemic
we have seen in over a hundred years and
we're fighting through it
we are this close to a vaccine
that will work we are finally fighting
through it
and we're developing some opportunities
to make sure the american people are
protected as we go forward
when we've had the doctors that are out
there with the comments she has made
when you looked at the dr fauci's dr
burke's annual redfield
stephen hahn dr drawer all of these
doctors
who worked exceptionally hard for the
american people
the president has made some critical
decisions
all the way along the line tough
decisions
he made a decision on the china travel
ban when we had
less than a dozen known cases here in
the united states
he was the one who set up the air bridge
working with commercial companies
so we would develop and bring in ppe
in 27 hours instead of 27 days
he's the one who went to companies like
3m so we could
more rapidly manufacture the n95 mask
going forward he's the one who drove all
those efforts
and i heard the comments made about the
people we have lost
do not think for a minute that that has
not bothered us
it does because we know on the task
force
several of those people scores of those
people
died without relatives because they
couldn't get in because of covenant
we know that scores of them died on
ventilators
when they're under sedition sedation
because they didn't have an opportunity
to see
their loved ones that bothers us every
single day
don't think it doesn't and it bothers
the president and the president's been
very
confident that we're going to get to a
solution you want a president
you want a leader that displays
confidence
that we have something going forward
that we're going to win and beat this
virus
and that's what he's done all the way
along the line
i'm very proud of the president of the
united states
i'm very proud of the vice president
united states
i'm very proud of the task force and the
work it's done
i am not proud olivia troy
should the president be having these big
rallies thank you lieutenant general um
we appreciate you doing this
that um what we have here um with this
former disgruntled detailee
um and with miles taylor as well these
are not profiles and courage but these
are
profiles in cowardice less than two
months ago
uh now disgruntled former detailee
olivia troy proudly declared that she
was serving in the trump administration
it had been quote
the honor of her life troy said quote i
have witnessed
firsthand how dedicated and committed
all of you have been to doing the right
thing she wrote that
just about a month and a half ago troy
failed to speak up
and she struggled to keep up because she
was constantly complaining
about how exhausted and overwhelmed she
was coordinating conference calls and
scheduling meetings
troy's detail was cut short and now
she's cutting commercials for a french
club of quote never trumpers who are
desperate for relevancy
and the price of admission to this club
is fabricated smears
and flat out lies against president
trump troy joins the
similarly irrelevant miles taylor cnn's
latest contributor
taylor proudly posed for a photo with
the president smiling
ear to ear taylor wrote that quote it
was the honor of
his lifetime to serve as dhs chief of
staff
but miles couldn't go the distance those
who knew miles during his short time in
the administration knew he could not get
results
after he left dhs actually got the
results
and securing the border building the
border wall and more
desperate to please his new silicon
valley friends miles made up
lies against president trump to fit in
he can now rest easy at google having
earned his anti-trump
credentials and the approval of his big
tech peers uh neither of these
individuals knew the president but they
are certainly
uh try to profit trying to profit off
for their time
off of their time here in the white
house uh flat out lies and thank you
general kellogg for setting the record
straight thank you follow-up questions
you